Dear Ms. President Dear Ms.
Ambassador Dear colleagues, I am
extremely pleased to welcome you today in
Ukraine for the sixth time during a
full-scale war on the eve of the
adoption of important political decisions that are
highly anticipated by Ukrainian
society.
the main thing of our European
aspirations is you, Mrs. President, the biggest
advocate of Ukraine today. We believe
that Ukraine
will be a member of the European family of the
European Union in the near future, and we are grateful for your
huge contribution to our joint work.
Of course, we are
implementing all reforms. Thank you for your
high appreciation of the steps Ukraine is taking
despite full-scale Russian
aggression, the
support of Ukrainian society is as
high as ever, the highest, more than 90% of
Ukrainians want to see our country a
member of the European Union, and this is
extremely important for us as
politicians. Of course, this is an important step for
our country
existentially
grateful also for our joint work on the
Ukrainian plan Ukraine facility this is an
important document for the development of our
state in order for us to be a
European country this document
is being prepared by our teams I am grateful to
both teams for the hard work that
is taking place I hope the document will be
on time I am convinced that the document
will be approved and agreed on time and this
will allow us to move forward for
Ukraine in the implementation of reforms for the
European Commission of the European Union
in support of our state during these
difficult times. I also thank you for your
personal contribution to the formation and support of the
solidarity corridors that enable us
to survive today  in the conditions of blocking
all kinds of export blocking by Russia,
our enemy,
I thank you for the financial support of
Ukraine During this year, it is the highest, the
largest, the European Union is to
date the
largest supporter, financial
donor of
Ukraine. Of course, we greatly
appreciate it. Thank you for the steps that were
taken in our relations  with
neighboring countries Thank you for your support in
energy security in the military
sector it is all extremely critical
even I would say important things today
During this war thank you again dear
ursula to you personally to your team thank you
for such powerful support and thank you again
for your symbolic important  visit
today for your next historic
speech in our parliament and thank you for this
meeting
Thank you very much Prime minister Dear
dennis UM for inviting me again and it
is an Honor To Be Here UM It was a Very
Special Moment for me to speak in the R
and now We have this very important
meeting our agenda is packed you have
been precise on the many Points We have to
discuss but this also shows How Deep
and Close The rel
I very muching for now to this and
We deeply committed to supporting
Ukraine in your  existential Fight so
Thanks Again for inviting
me Thank You So Much Dear colleagues if if
We May we will continue in very Fast
and Business
Man Yeah